antes de ir a lada los clientes eligen
ovejas para sacrificar mientras esperan
el fin de la violencia que asola su país
los sudaneses merecen algo mejor han
estado sufriendo durante tanto tiempo y
todavía tienen una gran fe en Dios mire
como continúan con sus rituales en medio
de la lucha
el ejército sudanés y los paramilitares
de las fuerzas de apoyo rápido han
anunciado sendos altos al fuego para la
festividad islámica desde que estallaron
los combates en abril varios altos al
fuego anteriores han fracasado un día
antes de la última tregua los combates
se recrudecieron en la capital jartum
donde el ejército está perdiendo terreno
a pesar de su superioridad aérea los
paramilitares dijeron el domingo que
habían tomado la principal base policial
de la capital los combates son graves
también en la región occidental de dafur
donde Estados Unidos Noruega y el Reino
Unido han condenado las violaciones
generalizadas de los derechos humanos y
la violencia étnica y sexual llevadas a
cabo principalmente por las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido y las milicias aliadas las
FARC dicen que están llevando a juicio a
miembros indisciplinados
la factor tomará medidas rápidas y
decisivas para abordar estos casos y
garantizar que se traten adecuadamente
el conflicto ha causado más de 3000
muertos y dos millones y medio de
desplazados y según Naciones Unidas más
de un millón de refugiados podrían huir
de Sudán antes de octubre